well there is also a lot of baby
excitement on the NCIS la said and
that's because daniela ruah is expecting
her second child and her TV love
interest Eric Christian Olsen is about
to become a dad again
- it's all in the family it could be
magical
yeah could be daniela ruah and Eric
Christian Olsen as Kensi and Deeks are
fellow agents and a couple on-screen but
in real life they are in-laws Daniella
is married to Eric's brother David Olsen
who is actually Eric's stunt double on
the show eric is married to actress
Sarah Wright and these two
sisters-in-law are both pregnant with
their second child I think a person who
has the most challenge from all of this
is Aris yeah oh yeah of course goes to
work in ESP when I'm like he doesn't get
a break from the show or motivated me
and so you know I'm they happened twice
both are already moms two little boys
and their baby girls will be born within
weeks of each other I've just always
wanted want to beat I have a really
great relationship with my mom and she
said to me um you know I would've been
happy no matter what you had but but as
a mom I'm happy that you get to have the
experience of having a girl for her
first baby
Daniella's bump was hidden on-screen how
will your pregnancy affect your show and
what your character is going through I
sort of gave them the news as we
finished the season it really is
difficult to plan around something like
this and they also like smile on their
faces we got this don't worry about it
and both ladies have a lot of pregnancy
cravings I was walking by this aisle and
I was just like flaming hot cheetos like
I want those two and and he's like he's
like no I will totally indulge in
chocolate melted white milk black but
maybe have cravings right now Daniella
told us she's not worried about getting
her body back into shape after the baby
because she enjoys working out and she
says that there's no pressure at work
because NCI FLA is a very
family-oriented show very nice great and
fired me
you